bueno esta operación que está ocurriendo
en estos momentos no es algo tampoco
reciente de hecho tiene varias semanas
de estarse dando operativos por parte de
las fuerzas de seguridad de israel en
coordinación con las fuerzas de
seguridad palestinas para intentar
desmantelar algunas organizaciones que
trabajan algo interno en este caso de
las zonas de nablús y otras regiones
esté controladas por la autoridad
nacional palestina lo que ha ocurrido
digamos en los últimos días que se dio
un enfrentamiento el más fuerte desde
mayo del año anterior ha sido un
intercambio de fuego verdad en el cual
israel anticipándose a eventuales
atentados por parte de la yihad islámica
que es una organización que se considera
terrorista por muchos países alrededor
del mundo
israel se anticipa a algún tipo de
operación por parte de la yihad islámica
y empiezan a hacer una serie de
operativos desde hace varios días
incluso a principios de la semana pasada
se dio el arresto de más a maldad y
verdad que debe ser uno de los líderes
de la yihad islámica en la región de
cisjordania y en estos días algunas
operaciones han dado digamos al traste
con la decapitación de la mayoría de la
cúpula militar de la yihad islámica
hablamos el caso de hoy de ibrahim
nablús y pero también la semana en estos
días durante el enfrentamiento se dio la
muerte de tasir al jabari y de khaled
mansur verdad lo cual e incluso digamos
señalaba como decía anteriormente la
decapitación de la mayoría de los
líderes de la yihad islámica que están
presentes el alto el fuego que fue
negociado principalmente por egipto lo
que buscaba era evitar que se siguieran
dando enfrentamientos entre israel y los
grupos palestinos que controlaban gas a
los cuales una vez empezado la operación
de lanzar una andanada de cohetes que
algunos incluso pues impactaron dentro
de zonas palestinas cobrando la vida
incluso de palestinos también si para
ella ni yo quería preguntarle qué es
exactamente el grupo yihad islámica y
qué rol juega en este conflicto porque
muchas veces hablamos del conflicto
entre elija más pero que es la yihad
islámica
bueno la yihad islámica es un grupo que
es muy similar a él jamás aparece en los
años 80 tiene una ideología de carácter
islamista sin embargo se han alejado un
poco de los principios por ejemplo la
hermandad musulmana que era bajo los
cuales se regían en un inicio al igual
que como lo hace el hamas y en este caso
han tenido un acercamiento muy muy
importante con teherán con el gobierno
de irán incluso y adnan halle que es el
principal el líder de la yihad islámica
mientras se daba esta operación entre
israel y la yihad islámica en gaza en
días anteriores estaba en teherán
buscando patrocinio verdad es un grupo
islamista que tiene más que todo
participación de carácter militar verdad
lo que es terrorismo propiamente a
diferencia del hamas que además de tener
un brazo paramilitar tiene un brazo
político y algo que los ha llevado a
gobernar el enclave costero en este caso
desde el año 2006 en mi caso la yihad es
una agrupación un poco más pequeña que
el hamas tiene principalmente
de carácter militar y como les dije
anteriormente tienen la mayoría de sus
acciones supeditadas a lo que se
dictamine desde teherán e incluso tienen
relaciones con el hezbollah libanés que
está ubicado digamos directamente en
este otro país